[Music]
hello everybody uh my name is
ilya nishnik
i am
a grandmaster from ukraine and i'm going
to be
showing you guys today some stuff i find
fascinating
uh the topic for
my tonight's lecture is
dynamic sacrifices for a long-term
advantage so it's a
it's um
a slightly more advanced topic i would
say
because um
i can't emphasize enough how important
it is to have active pieces right when
your pieces are active
you can just
do so much more with your position right
and sometimes
i would even say more often than not it
is worth it to
sacrifice something you may not need in
the long run just to have your pieces
active and
as useful as they can be
so
for example
in this game between uh
two very strong remasters
the issue right now is clear right the
issue is that
black's work is under attack
the bishop is one
attacking the rook and black needs to do
something about it
there is only
two real options here right can you guys
tell me what are the two real options
black has
can black do
to save the rook
well the second option is not really a
real option quote unquote because it
still loses material
so what do you guys think
yeah so today is actually my last
official day of uh of
uh being grow master in residence but i
will i'll be around for the next week
yeah yeah correct so rookie e5 rook
moves away bishop takes c6
using the fact that the pawn is pinned
this just wins the piece right so that's
that's the uh the
the bad second option that saves the
rook but loses the knight there is also
another bad option which is to capture
the pawn using the queen
yeah so rocky five people are pointing
under k5 is losing that's correct so rk5
was a
is a is a false path right a queen takes
b6 would be
less bad but still black would find
themselves
without an exchange right now white can
follow through with moves like rogue d5
inflicting double attack here and you
know nobody really wants to be playing
down material
especially when you have nothing to show
for it so yes the correct move here the
only correct way is to take on b6 with
the rook and here is
the critical moment of the game where um
um
mishra abhimanyu
went too easy on his opponent so the
move
ahimani has played is bishop captures c6
by the way we should probably i should
probably point out that at this point
white is down upon
right white is down the pawn and and in
my mind bishop captured c6 was a clear
attempt to win the pawn back and that's
kind of what happened so the game
continued as follows black obviously we
captured it was a rook white captured
the their missing pawn on e5
and after the next few couple of moves
the position really got really
simplified so just to fast forward
through
the next couple of moves
at this point
uh
uh tita streamer vicious has made a very
very nice practical decision because
if you guys can see
currently two of black's pieces are
under attack and black cannot save both
but has to choose between saving the
pawn and d5 and saving the rook and
actually titus made an amazing practical
decision to give up the rook
and he transposed into the following
almost an end game right we have quite a
few heavy pieces still on the board but
the thing is that
the a2 pawn and the b4 pawn are likely
to get traded just just like what
happened in the game and here we have
this position that's extremely difficult
for white to win yes white is up
material because white has a rook and
black has a bishop and a poem for it but
in reality
black has no weaknesses and if black if
white keeps trading pieces then
eventually
white king is not great yes this
correctly unfortunately black does not
really have
any any way to
use that right so the king is on h1 it
is somewhat exposed on this diagonal
right
but
really nothing black can do about it
and obviously black bean down material
would be more than content with a draw
and that's what happens over here um
abhimanya allowed the clean trade
transpose into us into the end game and
the end game appeared to be
drawn unfortunately white cannot make
progress even though they're up and
exchange because black just has this
kind of sort of a fortress
why can i not all because i have to have
to choose the next small right so let's
say ghost rock c8 and black i think
black eventually
went g6 came to g7 and just stood there
and did nothing and because black had no
weaknesses and white is lacking pieces
to to attack um black's position that's
why the game ended in a draw very
quickly so
um this kind of tells us that maybe just
maybe in the very beginning
not enough pawns here pretty much not
enough pawns and and even if all the
pawns get traded off then the rook
versus a bishop end game is a is a
theoretical draw so this actually tells
us maybe in the very beginning
at this point where white ended up
losing a pawn
maybe at this point white could have
just played on without oversimplifying
right so whenever you go for trades
you're simplifying the position and
you're going further into the
close to or into the end game right
um
oftentimes
i mean obviously it all depends all
depends on what
you know what you are expecting from
from your position
but oftentimes um trading pieces favors
the sentence defending
right so over here
if we just compare
every single piece in our position to
every single piece in black's position
we will
see clearly that black has no attack in
pieces right
none of black pieces are doing anything
other than defending right rook is the
defender knight is a defender bishop is
a defender twin defense queen also
defining rook and fe does nothing right
our pieces on the other hand most of
them right most of our pieces are purely
attacking pieces
right when we look at this position this
way
we can clearly see that our pieces are
doing a beverage i mean they are
in command whenever you have an
attacking piece versus a defending piece
an attacking piece dictates what's
happening right because the defending
piece is forced to maintain its position
to defend something attacking peace is
not forced to maintain its position to
keep attacking it can move away it can
do whatever else it wants right that's
always very nice
whenever you can choose what you want to
do and here yes that's correct basically
you guys can probably already tell okay
i've drawn i've drawn all these arrows
and it's kind of becoming clear
what is it that white is trying to or
what what is it that white is missing
here right
because as we
noticed
most of white's pieces are amazing
most but not all which piece in white's
position is not
doing much
anybody here
which piece in white's position is not
yes that is correct this rook on a1 it
is the only piece it's not attacking so
what do you guys think the strongest
move in this position would be
people in the chat already got it yep
pretty much everyone good job
yeah roxy one exactly
bringing in the very last piece into the
attack and actually this move uh is
surprisingly difficult for black to deal
with
because um
i think the most
uh the most obvious response here for
black would be a move such as
bishop b7
right because if bishop is if black is
not going to defend the bishop in c6
they'll lose it right so just just to
demonstrate because the d7 pawn is still
pinned
this would cost black
a piece well in this case a rope that's
that's awful right so to not let this
happen black either needs to get an
additional defender for the knight in c6
or
move the queen away from the pin right
so this queen is kind of under the pin
under the rook's pen and it
maybe we can find somewhere to move it
to what do you guys think can the queen
move anywhere to the right let's say e7
right because the queen was also a
defender it was defining the b6 rook so
moving it to sarai would cause blacker
rook again what about queen to c7
queen to c7
uh
uh it changes issue not changes but
little queen to c7 move solves
this issue but gets a new one right the
correct yeah yeah knight takes e5 you
overloading the queen right because the
queen is
still defining zero so knight takes e5
works amazingly because now black
captures an e5 it takes a rook if net
captures on e5 once again this issue of
queen been pinned is still there so
that's gonna cause black the queen and
here we are still maintain all of our
pieces are still attacking and and we
want our pawn back right so this is
amazing unlike the previous case where
white traded off too many of their
attacking pieces
just you know in an attempt to win their
pawn back so here i would say bishop to
b7 is probably one of the best moves
black can do
but this creates a new issue for black
because the bishop nc8 was also kind of
a defender
of the d7 pawn right so now
black is
getting a new issue that they cannot
really
solve that easily what is that issue and
what is white's next move going to be
okay it takes any file i think this time
it's just going to lose a piece because
there is no pen going on in the c file
right so black can just capture the the
knight
but you're you have a correct idea right
we're trying to we're trying to see if
you can win our pawns back because i
think one of the pieces right now might
be overloaded right the piece is
overloaded is the pieces
that's doing a lot of the jobs at the
same time and it cannot do all of all of
those jobs well
okay people in the shot already got it i
see the right answer
bishop takes c6 would kind of do the
same thing as in the game but here i
think black can even trade up
uh another pair of rooks right because
now if you want to win your i mean you
can take on e5 immediately but this
leads to a rook trade and actually after
d5 black is going to trade even more
stuff and this is kind of what what
we're trying to avoid right because our
pieces are so much better than black
pieces we do not
want to we don't we don't want to trace
them
off the board
um so yeah mate bishop t6 is definitely
a move but
it is not objectively the best move that
we have here
bishop b3
okay so you are transferring the bishop
onto this diagonal trying to play
pressure against f7 pawn
um
i would say it's definitely uh it is
definitely an idea that's worth
considering but we have something
stronger
right we have something immediate
something stronger something is going to
okay everyone in the chat got it by now
yes
yes right because the queen is now
overloaded as i said as i mentioned oops
drawing is hard so the bishop is the
bishop was doing this job now the queen
has to be doing this job actually it has
to be doing two jobs cannot do both of
them well
so we win our pawn back and look at
what's happening to bugs
not that this is what's hap
ah
this mouse and i are not friends i'm
sorry uh
oh my god what's what is going on it
just keeps doing that i will apologize
uh never mind
we're good
okay so this is what's happening the
white the black knight is now getting
pinned white has just won their pawn
back and black is gonna be in a bit
trouble very soon right not spent now e5
is coming the knight is
not just it's not just pinned it's
actually in big trouble as well because
we have three attackers right against
against uh black's two defenders so i
guess the next move is going to be roxy
but you see how how pinned black black
pieces are like i think if we if we are
to try and find a good move for black
right now we wouldn't we wouldn't
succeed right and all this is because we
didn't rush right so we identified that
our pieces are just so much better than
our opponents that we don't have to rush
to win back our material we can do it
anytime
but waiting and improving the very final
piece which was the rook and a1 right
waiting one move improving this piece is
actually going to allow allow us
to win our pawn back
and more right because here i think at
this point black physically has no
better move other than bishop to b7
um this knight cannot move as it's
defending the e5 we already determined
that the queen cannot move
the rook cannot move as well because
white is threatening to capture the
knight so black's position is pretty
much doomed
yeah so this is my first example it's
rather
simple and straightforward but it just
shows you guys how important it is to
identify the possible the possibility of
having
an immense peace activity and
more often than not
pieces that are this active
is just going to be a great long-term
investment because you're going to get
more than what you've put put up for
put up for it
for peace activity
let's move on
and take a look at this game now
this game is from the same event
uh
the usual suspect um mishra up himani
was playing as black here and he was
unfortunately this time he was
in a loser's seat playing against grand
master ali miranda semel khan who also
goes by jj
um
so in this position
mishra had
a rather difficult choice what to do
black is up a pawn
yet again
we are continuing the topic of one side
being up upon but here the issue is
slightly different than before black
does not really have any well not any
but doesn't really have that many
weaknesses
and white doesn't really have that many
ways to utilize their
space advantage because clearly white
has a superior center right both pawns
are in the center they are allowing
white to control a couple of important
squares
but there isn't much what can do with it
right now well the black bishop is
taking care of it
so
black also has
an issue that's oftentimes not an issue
at all so the king is in the center but
because the pawn structure is so locked
locked up
right there isn't
much white can do to this king
at the same time black does not really
want to hide the king anywhere but will
physically cannot go short castle
why
short castle is a blunder
where
net over here
well i'm afraid black just has way too
many defenders so this is likely to be
an unfavorable trade for white right so
this will happen and white ends up
losing another pawn
uh yeah so i see the answers in the chat
something is unprotected now something
that white can capture for free
h6 pawn correct just bishop captures h
bishop captures h6
forces the rook away and well since
white captured their missing pawn back
now they don't have to worry about
having to prove that they have a
superior peace activity which they they
still do i believe that white can just
follow through with an attack well maybe
not immediately because their own d4
pawn is hanging so i feel like what
white could have done here would be a
move like room t1
taking care of their weak d4 pawn and
then follow it up with h4h5 breaks
through against the black king um the
king is
not safe at all if it casts a short
right even if even if not as that even
if white did not win the pawn on h6 even
if y just played h4 h5
that's that's really concerning for the
black king right black black would have
to play something like g5 or h5 move
the kingside pawns further up and that's
that would jeopardize
the king's safety so
black doesn't like button uh
doesn't really want a castle short at
any point
casting long but also be questionable
right because there is an open file
there is an a open file that verb white
already has a rook there is also going
to be a semi-open c file
where white can bring
their second rook and that's that's
that's a point of concern for black
right they don't want they don't really
want to be under under the x-ray or both
of white rooks so this is definitely
better this castle does not lose any
material but it's still questionable
whether black would be feeling safe
after castling their king queen side
however if the king remains in the
middle
well
the only thing black really needs to be
concerned about is one of these checks
right that's the only direct way for
white to attack the black king but both
of them are not really doing much we
already determined that knight to f6
loses white upon knight to d6 would
force a trade like black can trader
black bishop for the white knight and
then you know and then the pawn would
let's make a random move to um
to discover what would happen
had white
played knight d6 so we would see this
trade happening and now the d6 pawn is
kind of loose right so d6 pawn may
become an easy target so the the easiest
way i see for black to capture the d6
pawn would be to play knight f6 attack
wait first of all
first of all i'm
i'm a little bit blind
what am i missing here i'm missing a
very simple move right
that black can make
like a really simple one there's
something that's hanging in one and i'm
not seeing it
yeah exactly just not just hanging on c3
i'm not sure what what happened to me
uh but yeah so here if white
uh if white does not want to lose a p
their p they have to capture in d5 first
and then capturing g6 which loses them
upon by the way
i'm not going to jump the train but i'm
going to say that this position actually
or position
very close to this one this happened in
the game and i'll explain why so this
idea of knight d6 is going to be the key
idea for y2 to break through
black's
central bone structure so let's actually
take a look at what happened in the game
here black went a5
and now actually knight d6 would be the
transposition to the position and it
happened in the game but i believe yes
y2k and d5 first
and over here
we already know knight f6 is not
doing much right it gives up the pawn by
the way knight d6 that was played in the
game also gives up the pawn but it does
something that knight f6 doesn't do
so knight d6 forces black to trade their
bishop off you know it forces this trade
otherwise the king has to move somewhere
i'm not sure there is a safe place for
the king to go to if it goes to f8 which
is the only
move i see that black can make this move
immediately loses right at f7
with a double attack
so king f8 doesn't seem very safe for
the king right if it can get to g7
that's the usual
king placement when you're making a
castle by hand so if you if you're
forced to move your king
and it's not a castle you call it a
castle by hand if you if you know it
takes quite a quite a few extra moves
than than the normal castle but
eventually the king is is looking to get
to g7 or h7
not only is it a massive time race but
also as we mentioned before king is not
very safe on the king side anyway
so um
any other move that white makes does not
force black to trade their their squid
bishop right so after knight d6
black token d6
it takes d6 and queen takes distance
right so here is here is why
the we're looking at another sacrifice
right we're looking at the sacrifice of
the second pawn which generally
is a very
uh
i don't want to say the word unsafe
thing to do but if you're sacrificing as
much material as two pawns you
oftentimes you have to like
you know be
extremely quick about your attack
because anything that's a that's above
one pawn anything that you sacrifice is
above one pawn gives your opponent
an immense possibility to give it back
to give one of the pawns back to
reorganize their pieces and then they'll
if they succeed they'll still have
another pawn
as in as a as an extra pawn and that's a
big advantage so
over here what has to be
as fast with their attack as possible so
every single move that white would make
as you guys will see momentarily is
going to be applying some kind of
pressure in in onto the black's position
so bishop f4 is
obvious
what is rating range for this class
rating range for this class i would say
probably
um 1500 to 2000 maybe 1500 to 2100 so
it's wide
um there's
quite a few tactics here and quite a few
things to understand so that's that's
how i would rate this class
okay i missed quite a few quite a few uh
chat messages up on apple hs i'm trying
to catch up
um
closed centers closed centers favors the
knights better exchange bishops but oh
okay so you're saying that that this
trade is not good because
because uh white gets a bishop pair and
bishops are not great and in close pawn
structures that's that's correct by the
way that's a good point but here you see
in chess
just like in many other uh
fields uh
in life the uh the answer to
certain questions is it depends on other
factors so here
uh
we have a couple of other factors that
influence that influence the generic
generic rule about not trading knights
in close bone structures because here we
can make an immediate use of our dark
squared bishop and this is kind of why
we're going for this trade
so black over here black played queen b4
and once again if
if white is not going to attack
immediately black has a rather simple
way of reorganizing their pieces at this
point the only bad thing about well not
the only black thing about best position
but one of the bad things about black
expedition is that their rooks are not
connected and as we know
black cannot castle so i believe that
the black's next move is going to be
which move to connect the rooks
using the fact
that the pawn structure is still
closed in the center
black is probably not afraid to keep the
king in the center right black doesn't
want to castle but black would
definitely like to connect the ropes
yeah i see the correct answer
blood bishop on b7 is is another problem
that's gonna cost black the game
probably i would say because of this
bishop black or partly because of this
bishop black and end up losing but yeah
what which which is the move that
connects the rooks without without
casper
yeah king e7 i think that's what black
is trying to do because the king oh the
only
way for white to attack the king would
be queen h4 but then there is g5 right
it blocks the attack and actually wins
the piece this is why i think key e7 to
connect the rooks maybe bring them in
that would be
that would be black's idea so white
cannot wait white plays rook a to c1 now
if king e7 happens i believe white has
rook to c7 and this
you know
attacking the bishop and b7 and pinning
the d7 knight looks rather
scary did this happen i wonder i think
this might have happened what happened
in the game no in the game black played
g5
okay so i guess black just wants to
discourage white from playing roxy seven
and that's why they go g5
forcing the black bishop to make a
choice right now the bishop has to move
somewhere
um well there's only two two places
right the e3 and c7
as we as we already know the c7 is kind
of reserved for for our rook right so i
wouldn't go to c7 which leaves
the e3
and now
black want king to e7
and here white did not play rook c7
right
on the contrary of what i've been saying
all this time roxy 7 did not happen
why
hold up
uh
ruxia okay okay so what are you guys
what what have you guys
planned against rook takes b7 are you
guys trying to catch the rook something
yeah eugene you're correct yeah that's
what that's literally what happened uh
but yeah now
eugene gave an answer from a different
perspective so he didn't give give an
answer
of what black can do to make roxy 7
ineffective but he gave an answer of
what white should have done instead of
roxy 7 and why roxy 7 is not effective
as as what white could have done
um so yeah i think the problem here is
that black can just defend the b7 bishop
and then their next move is going to be
rook c8 trading off one pair of rooks
when our bishop was in f4
black would definitely be very
uncomfortable having the rook on b8
right because it's gonna be under the
x-ray of the bishop as soon as the rook
moves away from c7
bishop on the f4 would be attacking the
rook and that's why black decided to
include the move g5
however the muji 5 creates an additional
possibility for what
now you see this is kind of what i mean
because
black is feeling uncomfortable
they
feel the need to
untangle and connect their pieces right
and in in
their attempt to do that black is giving
away
more and more
not advantage but they're giving away
they're making their position weaker so
the move some moves such as g5
look very logical right it's just an
attacking move that forces a bishop away
but in reality the g5 becomes a hook for
white pieces right now white can use the
pawn and g5 to to fuel up their attack
right so what do you guys think would be
a move to use this
g5 hook and help our attack
so eugene already got it i mean well
h4 yes correct so um
people were saying f4 as well in the
chat i believe that f4 is probably not
going to be as as effective because s4
f4
um
literally
kills our dark side bishop right so h4
still maintains uh
some possibilities for our bishop while
f4 i think there's a very very easy way
for black to just like destroy the
bishop just go f5 and go g4 and this
bishop is not going anywhere anytime
right it's walked by by our own pawns
so um
after h4 black still can play f5 right
but f5 is no longer as effective
after f5
our bishop is still
is still attacking the g5 by the way
here i believe um
we might be we might be having some some
tactics such as bishop takes g5
uh queen takes g5 and i feel like black
might just be uh
losing here because of how big their
king has become there's rook c7 that's
coming up right if king d6 actually kf7
seems to be the best move according to
the computer but i'm not sure if this
is holdable for black because white is
gonna join their bishop soon and this
this doesn't seem
doesn't seem very uh very safe for the
king um
on the other hand white probably does
not have to do this white could have
probably just played queen h5 or
any other queen move
and uh and
publishes
and now
if black captures on h4 we already know
that this creates
additional weakness for for black to
worry about now their king can be
attacked from the right side and that's
once again i guess there is no
um no real defense right if king f7 once
again the same plan is gonna is gonna
come through and the king will just keep
getting attacked
yeah so here blackberry f6 black is
trying to maintain the closed pawn
formation right if white captures on g5
now black would capture back with an h
pawn and maintain the the pawn shield
right so blacks keep keep misclicking uh
black's
um task here is to survive right as long
as they survive as long as their king
does not get
checkmated they probably will win
because they're up two pawns that's
that's a commanding material advantage
so
over here
white played another attacking move that
forces black to
think about how to defend and that move
is bishop to h3 once again f5 is there i
think f5 was the move that was the move
that was played
yeah f5 was played um
question why
why would a move such as queen to d6
not work because it's essentially it's
accomplishing the task right the task is
the current task the current black's
task is to define the e6
but for some reason black did not play
queen d6 queen d6 seems a bit more
logical because it maintains the same po
information right now
um
right that's that's that's the goal the
goal is to make sure the king is as safe
as possible and definitely not pushing
any more pawns near the king
would do a good job for black but for
some reason this wasn't played why why
so you're using the fact that the queen
is overloaded i'm not sure how effective
this is gonna be
okay so i see the answer in the chat
yeah i can
probably play
you know both king of fight and candida
losing a rook is
is unless you're checkmating here now
it's probably gonna
not gonna work in the long run right
because there's just way too many ways
for black to defend if you don't if you
don't attack right now black will
eventually get more pieces near the king
and defend
yeah losing the work is probably too
much
any other suggestions
a regular got it con got it
so we're dealing with tactics now
it's a tactics check
h6 g5 was suggested
um
the only reason for for why we would
like to take on g5 is if we
maybe take
here
but
in my mind i think taking in g5 is
almost never worth it because we're
helping black right we're opening the
edge file for the black rook and
unless we can
punish back punish black immediately
here they will eventually be able to use
this open file so
once again unless there is nothing
immediate i think taking is a bad idea
but maybe this works
i'm not sure if this works at all
doesn't seem like it is
okay you guys
do you guys see do you guys
want to give it another shot
over here
people are see people are seeing
people are saying rook to e1 in the chat
which actually makes a lot of sense
i actually like to move rookie one
rookie one two but i think we have an
immediate solution which is bishop to f4
okay bishop to f4 uses the fact that
black cannot take
black captures we have queen g7 and now
we are forcing the black king
back to the last string
you guys can probably tell what it's
going to lead to it's going to lead to
us winning the rook and there
you're not even we're going to be
even in material right at this point
we're even in material but we have a we
have a rook
for for a light piece and two pawns one
of which we're probably going to win
back momentarily but our attack still
goes on right our attack hasn't died
down we still have
a whole pleasure of different ways to
apply pressure against the black king
does the rook after e1 work i'm pretty
sure it should yeah i think rook after
e1 is a is is a good move also
because now i think we are amplifying
the spread of bishop of four and what i
mean by that is because well let's say
black makes a random move here actually
there's no good rook move for black at
this point so i think that the the
reason for why
now we're amplifying the year this
thread is because after bishop f4 we do
have rookie six
oh oh all right after bishop f4
okay let's check it out
rook e1
well
probably works honestly i think it works
um
i don't really see a defense for black
here i saw king d8
but
yeah honestly this looks like black is
going oh my god there's no move rock a6
here oh that's so cool
uh there's actually rookie six
black has f5 yeah so
they're making it unclear right so
they're making it unclear and i would
just go for for for a free rook after
bishop four
did i play in usm masters 2021 no last
time i played in us masters one two
thousand was in 2017 or 18 i don't do
well there
so i stopped playing there unfortunately
e5 was a defense here but you see if if
black plays e5 you can still win the
rook so my my only goal was this tactic
was to win the rook
and if i make a move such as rookie one
here
it
may or may not work right i know that
winning will work for sure okay now i'm
winning after winning the rook so
i would much rather just do that than
have have to calculate a line that's
not
that doesn't give me a clear
you know winning advantage
so
okay over here black fighter 5
and after qh5
the g5 pawn is still under attack right
black ventrac g8
now you see black is wasting a bit too
many resort too much too many resources
to
to protect the king because the king is
getting now getting attacked from the
right side right or or is about to get
attacked from the right side and white
is going to use this fat very very
efficiently so white plays rook c7 now
bishop c8 and just simply rock c1 so all
of the black pieces are tied tied down
i think the logical thing to do here
would be to play g4 and that's what
black did playing g4 kind of traps the
white queen but unfortunately does not
matter anymore
after bishop captures ch6 if black takes
this bishop now
how does white win
what is white's next move that basically
wins the game
bishop g5 correct let's check um king
does not really have any word to go it
if it goes to a fade white is going to
pick up the bishop and see if it goes to
d6 what has a checkmate in one rook c6
so the only way to survive a bit longer
is to take here
white would take
and um
wait no white would actually which oh
wow okay i almost fell into it which
room do you think that should take here
the rook on the g500 or the rook on h8
h8 okay why not g5
okay that's a good point so if you're
taking the shade so you're just going to
be keep maintaining this double attack
right but
the the the line in question here was
this right because
this is once again this is also a big
material advantage but there is
something black can do
yeah so take on c8
and queen e1 yeah this is what i've
missed and now there is a perpetual
check
because there is nothing on the e4 under
on the first frame to stop the queen
from checking us yeah so this is why we
have to take on h8 which probably wins
easier
overall
probably wins more material this way
yeah so
black was forced to make them quindy d2
which leads to this end game in this end
game black is currently up one pawn but
if you notice their bishop is under
attack and both b5 and a5 pawns are
under attack um i believe black lost
this game within the next couple of
moves because what happened was white
picked up both pawns on a5 and b5 as
their bishop
and then white began pushing their b4
pawn
and there was nothing black could have
done to stop to stop white from
promoting and therefore they just
resigned because they have no attacking
pieces all of their pieces are still
defending and actually after losing both
b5 and a5 they're down material right
they're down the pawn and they have
really they really have no hope
other than
hoping that black will or other than
hoping that white will screw up but that
didn't happen
so once again long-term advantage this
time it was
where we were missing two pawns instead
of one now on to the last game do you
guys have any
questions so if i'm moving too fast you
guys can always stop me
or pause me and and ask me to explain
myself
or to elaborate
oh um so
the opening i believe was um
it looks like slov defense where white
sacrificed the pawn right so black took
on c4 and swap defense and white played
b3 captures captures
uh this is this is a game between ali
miranda simulcan and mishra abhimanyu
from 2020 to spring classic
section b
uh so it was played this this year
earlier this year um in
um
march i believe i was playing in section
a at that time
so yeah
these positions are very tricky the
engine likes these positions for black
because it believes that the pawn is a
good enough advantage to to survive in
case you start getting attacked
but practically speaking i would say
it's easier to play with white because
the plants are
clearly defined and uh and black will
always be under the under the attack
under the pressure of having to defend
properly is it the catalan
uh it might have been catalan yeah or it
might have been uh might have been slow
i think
well if i were to guess i don't really
know i don't have a full game here but
oh from from
oh the plan for white here was to to
open up the position and white
accomplished this
right so black played a5 now and white
accomplished
their plan by trading the knight on d5
and then giving up another pawn this was
a position specific idea because in
general as somebody in the chat pointed
out usually you want to keep the knights
when the position is closed when the
pawn structure is closed you want to
keep the knights because they have
easier easier time maneuvering around
the pawns but in here white kept both
bishops
just for the sole purpose of using the
bishop on the 4 to infiltrate in a c
file
6
let's see okay so rook to c1
uh-huh
okay yeah it probably would be i think
it would be because black doesn't really
have much much to do i think maybe black
would have played a4 here
and and created some kind of past pawn
so now we would have the same thing but
black actually does have some contour a
counter play right because they have a
pass pawn that white cannot really
ignore
so maybe this is why white was in a
hurry to you know to do the the the
sacrifice
that's that's my that's my guess
okay any other questions
yeah correct yes so use the bishop to
help the rook infiltrate on the c7
can black play queen b6 because black
played queen before i believe
yeah
proxy one right
oh just rook c8 okay let's see
i will probably just takes and goes goes
back yeah
and then yeah bishop b7 then we're gonna
go rock c7 and bishop a6 we can go rogue
c6 and we're just gonna make the
bishop's life leaving hell if not when i
think
we might win it here no
i'm not doing sure how i can defend yeah
so yeah this is probably why black was
immediately trying to connect the rooks
to make sure this doesn't happen and
they played kingston
significant that fight is doing
something correct exactly yes this is
essential why didn't if i didn't play
this this aggressively they would just
they would have lost the game they they
had they have to they're obliged to play
this way
okay wait let me close this
any other questions
okay i guess let's move on
ah
arrows i like drawing arrows but i'm not
very good at it
this game is from my section same event
but section a
remastered dragon camille versus
promaster ray robson
my good friend who lives
nearby
and uh
in the game
white made uh
an inaccuracy
or
it's it's i would probably say it was
more than an accuracy because white put
too much hope
into their own attack on the queen set
right so in this in this case
um they have a pretty unbalanced pawn
structure right white has
nice pawns in c4 and d4 and white also
has a pretty nice
battery going on this
diagonal which kind of tells us
or tells us about the possibility of
what the best move here might be for
white
what do you guys what do you guys think
yeah okay arian already got it the best
move here for white is it's
more of a rhetorical question after i
gave you guys all these hints
best move is d5 and even though it's
probably going to cost by the pawn in
the long run they are gonna win their
pawn back it is very very difficult
oh and then see if i was c5 that's
over here instead of taking you want to
play c5 now huh okay well
you're you have giving up two pawns
you're gonna win one of them back
but in the process we are trading
a white piece right i'm not sure if we
have if white has enough white only has
two pieces attacking white has a rook
and the queen attacking but black look
at how many pieces black has near the
king i think this is probably not gonna
work for whites the knight cannot join
the bishop cannot join
right so it's probably gonna be
close i mean okay white can just capture
the pawn on f5 but then black has
contour attack of their own
so
and then it joins vf4 okay so maybe
maybe here
might be uh i might be messing up maybe
it's just knight e7 then
is my e7 working
knight e7
let's see
there was there was a solution here like
i i've checked this move but um
there was a way for black to defend
against all that maybe just not not
maybe just not take the opponent's five
no but i should probably should
uh how do i defend
97 yeah i 97 doesn't work because
there's bishop b5 and now the rook on e8
is overloaded
let's see
maybe i can just make a draw i don't
know if i'm i'm not sure if i want to
draw if i'm black maybe i can just
force force you to trade a rook and uh
and it's going to be fine because you
can never checkmate me if if you have no
rooks
yeah rookie seven yeah that's that's my
guess we can we can cheat and ask the
engine but there should be a way for
white to or for black to uh
to defend themselves here
but yeah if y just takes on d5 actually
it's probably probably gonna be as good
if not better you're gonna get kind of
the same position but
um
without the pawn in d5 for black now
you know
you don't have to worry about
the black ball never promoting but
obviously the question is not what white
should have done here i mean i mean i
guess it is a question as well but uh
but we are actually going to be looking
at this position from black perspective
now so white play the move queen b6 i
guess attempting to play d5 right now if
white plays d5 this pawn is penned and
it's going to be it's going to be a
better version of what we've been trying
to do in the beginning
um
as we notice here
white has moved a significant portion of
their pieces over the queen set right so
white has three pieces and a queen side
black only has one
but at the same time black has a nice
concentration of pieces on the king side
which may give us some idea about a
potential attack right we have a we have
pieces in the king side we have um good
connected pawns in the middle
this should call for action
what do you guys think black black did
here
to initiate
the attack
[Music]
yeah i'm i'm trying i think there's a
way to uh
just do it in one click but yeah okay so
i see the answer yeah okay so yeah
couple of couple of people already got
it
the most obvious way to begin the attack
right we need to start exposing the
white king right on the king side so um
f4 is one of the moves but it might be a
bit too slow because well
i mean e3 yeah e3 is the correct move
yeah f4 is is probably okay but but it
allows y to have a neck to have one move
uh and that move is going to be d5 right
and then we're gonna eventually play e3
anyway and then and then it's gonna cost
us the pawn on c6 so it's it's once
again it becomes unclear but if we play
e3 right now white cannot wait what can
not wait for us to take on f2 right what
can't can't allow us to take on f2
because it just loses the game
immediately right our knight falls
through with knight e4 and g3 and it's
game over so what has to capture
now the question is do we cap do we
recapture on e3
exactly so once again if we capture an
e3 white gets a couple of moves that
they can use to reorganize their pieces
and maybe even launch their own counter
attack right now for example bishop b4
followed by rogue b8
d5 is there as well so yeah rook e3 is a
bit a bit too slow so if you're
yeah okay queen just three too good
queen just three double double
explanation mark because clintus iii
forces white into
defending right queen takes e3 as a big
threat we need three comes with a double
attack against the king and the bishop
uh and also there is an e4 threat knight
e4 also comes with a double attack
what double attack is the e4 it's
attacking the bishop and also it's
helping
yeah helping queen f2 and knight g3
would be a checkmate if white ignores
that
so
white's response is pretty much force
now knight f3 what would happen if black
played in e4 now
what has a very very effective defense
here
yeah bishop e1 yeah bishop one takes
care of everything now this is the time
where black knows they screwed up
because they have to move back they're
down the pawn their attack is has gone
nowhere
yeah everyone in the chat got it as well
so after knight f3 black just took
right back took on e3 which
once again
makes it a double attack the f3 knight
is hanging because the g to pawn is spin
the c3 bishop is hanging so
actually white does not have a way to
avoid losing material here right because
both of these pieces are hanging white
cannot save both so white decided to
give a check a probe in check to see a
black blunder or something but did not
blunder they played bishop to e8
obviously king h7 would be a blunder
because then black holes is the bishop
on f7 so bishop e8 is one of the good
moves knight to e8 would also work but
bishop e8 is is is a bit more precise
and here after bishop e1
to win material black obviously have to
capture right because if if the queen is
forced forced to move away then there is
no talk about winning anything so black
captured the e1
white captured by capture the knight
now we have
black having two pieces for a rook and
the middle game right two pieces for a
rook
is is great news plus the white king is
as big as ever
so i guess this is why white
knew that they have to try something
aggressive right if y just doesn't do
something active something aggressive
they're going to lose because black
knights are coming in and it's just
going to be game over
but still wins after k h7 probably but
once again we we need to we need to be
as as objective as possible and kh7 is
very saying that over here
right h7 still wins but i mean
like now we have to worry about queen
takes of six right
like even if we do even if we are
winning you're probably correct because
i think you're
actually are you
how or how are we winning here i see a
draw
i don't i don't see a win
i mean i see night
where actually i don't yeah no i don't
see a win yeah because here at first i
said this is winning but then i realized
that queen h4 is not a checkmate
right so uh this this was the only yeah
the only tactic that they saw that might
have won for black but other other than
that i mean i guess we can try like h4
we should lose because
now white can simplify right and this is
once again my point that we don't need
to go for this because it's too
complicated that we don't want to spend
our time as we see an easier way to win
so let's go back here
now white played queen c7 obviously
trying to apply as much pressure as
possible so now queen g7 is threatening
only defense actually
one of the
few defenses is net to h5 right
defending and preparing to attack at the
same time knight at some point is
looking to
join the attack against the white king
by playing ng3
so white goes from b8 and while rook b8
is not really
actually
maybe it does have a direct threat what
do you guys think the direct threat is
of rugby of rogue b8
it is obviously not to capture
yeah just queen takes c6 you're using
the fact that bishop is spent yeah so uh
the easiest
way to combat that is just move the king
away from the last ranks kh7 did happen
now white played king h2
and this is a good time for blood to
begin
their advance right so
i guess black decided to trade bishops
first the queen takes f1 happens rook
takes e8 and at this point nothing has
really been threatening to white to
black so they
begin their knight advance the glorious
knight advance and that goes to f4 there
is only one way to protect
white against
the czech maiden one what takes on c6
and this knight is going to go
to f6 trying to get to which square why
is the knight going backwards
you mean you probably mean e4 but yeah
that's correct because right now the
only defender against the checkmate is
the queen so the black knight is just
trying to get to e4
to to block
the only defender um at this point
knight e4 is def definitely does the job
but but also the move knight e2 does it
because 92 threatens the maiden g1 which
cannot be
yeah cannot be uh
stopped
well i guess white can suffer for a
couple extra moves but in the end it's
still at all it all the same
so
this was my last example and once again
as we can see it is pretty much
all about peace activity right so we
gave up a pawn and in the long run and
these examples are were
i would say they're they were rather
simple because
quote-unquote long run
was about
four to five moves at most right uh
sometimes it's gonna take even longer
than that sometimes it's gonna take you
know multiple attempts to improve your
pieces to gain to regain your your
material balance and then more right but
that's eventually that's the goal that's
what's going to happen if you do it
correctly and this is why i believe
um
this is why i believe materialistic
approach is not necessarily the best
approach right
most people have hard time partying with
their pieces even if they are clearly
bad and and not not very useful
um
why not just
give them up and make the rest of your
army as good as they can be it's
gonna work
more often than not your opponent will
get scared
because they're being attacked and yeah
you're gonna win as opposed to having
one bet piece is probably gonna cost you
the game so
this was me
and my uh
the next sacrifice for a long-term
advantage lecture i hope you guys
enjoyed it
um and yeah i'll i'll see you guys at
some point this week
um
i guess that is it
so yeah
my pleasure
for everyone watching online i hope you
guys have a
great rest of your day
[Music]
you